who do you think is the most underrated
player that you ever
share the court with in the nba just
someone who doesn't get enough love
enough flowers for how good they are or
what they bring to the game
j.r smith
jr
j.r smith i think uh
at one point i even
told j.r he was
like he was talking to me like i'm like
brown know who you think i am bro but i
used to play with you on the video games
oh for sure on 2k with with the nuggets
and with the hornets
like he was at one point though it was
like but that's what i mean about the
league like
i remember when he was on the nuggets he
was having like
like i think he had a 50-point game yeah
yeah like
he's like i said when he when jr is hot
it's automatic but it was like because
so many people put him into that
category of like he's got to be hot he's
streaky he's right he's got behavioral
problems it's like bro he was 18. y'all
put him in the league and gave him some
money
he's gonna make like he had to grow up
in front of everybody everyone's eyes
i'm like bro that sucks and now y'all
putting him in a weird role y'all
talking about my dog like at one point
jr was talking to me i'm like bro you
are j.r smith i don't know what the [ __ ]
you talking about right now
you're j.r smith don't forget that yeah
like i don't know what you on right now
i used to play video games with you fam
like not
shoulder to shoulder [ __ ] like
i'm going on the fantasy draft to make
sure i got j.r smith on my roster
like you not going to talk to me like
that bro you going to talk to me like
you jr smith yeah i think you're going
to teach me [ __ ] that j.r smith should
be teaching me and you gonna walk first
like you know what i'm saying like
that's how i felt about jr cause it's
like bro y'all like even went on that
team it was like people didn't
understand i was still 20 21 year old
that was like i went from being at
georgia tech
lockout hitting i'm at chicago i'm
really i'm in chicago just kicking it i
got the homies we
i got ready for the for the league [ __ ]
literally just playing with my homies
every day we just playing ball in the
gym
we're doing our own sprint drills yeah i
wasn't paying a train or nothing it was
just going for blood playing ball every
day with them talking [ __ ] so it was
like bro i went from that to
mello is my teammate amari is my
teammate
uh
tyson baron davis mike bibby i'm looking
around like [ __ ] i'm like don't
forget my baby was on that team treyarch
smith you just came from china to play
on my team like i'm like this man on my
team bro i'm throwing them lives i'm
like gee i threw those i threw this [ __ ]
to j.r today so what he caught that
video backwards
i just i think jr like is under
appreciated but i also think like oh no
he's still everybody's favorite i just
think people love him yeah for sure
but under appreciated and undervalued as
a player as a player there's no reason
he should have never touched in a 100
million dollar contract that's what i
mean like
we're not going to sit here
and
like it's just other players that got
paid just because they were a good guy
and i didn't like that